have to say this has been the most  exciting the most eventful and certainly  one of the most spectacular series of  championships that we've ever run  somebody would have told me eight years  ago that we were going to be hosting the  US Chess Championships here in st. Louis  for eight years in a row would have been  hard to believe  the winner of this year of the US  Women's Championship please welcome  nause McKenzie the new champion of the  United States Championship Grandmaster  fabiano caruana we can't just have a US  Championship or a US Women's  Championship we have to do more the top  three finishers from the championship  along with grandmaster Kasparov will  play a series of round-robin blitz  tournaments against each other we are in  for a very exciting event  you